What do I say to someone I've trained in later claims this person claims that a
certain thing was not covered in the training.
Uh,
in addition to the questions is obviously excuses,
obviously excuses.
So this is uh,
this is a really pretty common question of how do you handle these situations.
And I've actually been lucky enough in my life to run a lot of training into a
lot of different situations,
mostly in the military.
And I've absolutely had this happen.
And there's one thing that I do when this happens and you can probably guess
what it is,
I take ownership of it.
So check it out.
If somebody comes to me and says,
Oh,
you were supposed to train us on x and you didn't,
and I know that I did and it was in the curriculum and we covered it,
I say,
I don't say no,
I trained you in it.
Here it is.
No,
I say,
okay,
let's get it trained then.
Or do I gotta do lay?
Here it is.
Let me Redo the curriculum.
Let me show it to you again because here's the thing,
as a trainer,
it's not just your job in this,
what I used to tell my guys when I ran training,
the guys that one of the instructor cadre,
I'd say,
listen,
it isn't your job just to run the training,
just to provide the training.
It is your job to ensure that the training is absorbed.
That's the difference.
That's a big difference between philosophies of training.
I my goal when I'm training someone who is to make sure that the training is
absorbed into the mind.
Otherwise go watch a youtube video cause a youtube video.
You can see the same instruction.
Yeah,
but no,
I need to seek you out and say,
okay where did,
where did you miss it?
Where did and also where did I fail in my training if I covered it,
why don't you remember it?
Yeah,
that means I didn't cover it well enough or I didn't teach it well enough and I
think that [inaudible] then you retrain them.
You get them up to speed.
At some point they're going to realize that you did train them.
I mean,
if they truly forgot or even if they didn't forget,
but they're just placing the blame on you,
they're going to realize that,
you know,
they're going to know that you know,
that you trained them when they,
when you reflect on the same information and do it again.
So I think it's pretty simple answer.
Uh,
when someone is saying you haven't trained them,
take responsibility for it.
Take ownership for it and say,
okay,
well then let me get you trained on it.
My,
my apologies.
I'm here to train you.
Let me make sure that I train you and make sure that you absorb it.
Let's go.
I think that your way of training should be
done or performed with kids as well.
Like parents with their kids.
You know how you,
cause you know how the kid,
the kid's misbehaving and the parent's like,
I don't know why he does that.
I told him not to pitch a fit.
Oh yeah,
I know you probably told them or you went through the motions of telling them or
whatever.
But man,
you gotta you gotta train them and make sure that's absorbed.
You know?
Absolutely.
So,
and I always kind of think of it this way,
not kind of,
I really think of it this way where if your kid is misbehaving,
it's something you did or didn't
do of course.
So you can't really sit there and be like,
oh,
blaming the kid for misbehaving or whatever.
Or you know,
you're,
you're right.
I wonder,
isn't it weird that you can have families where one kid can go to go to high
school and do well and do great on their sats and get into a great college and
go to and go be a doctor and the other kid can become a heroin addict?
Yup.
Isn't that strange?
It
interesting.
But uh,
and I think long time ago I would talk to you about this like long time and how
do we blame the parents and well,
that's the thing.
That's the,
that's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying blame the parents.
I'm not saying that cause because that would,
if you're blaming them,
that's like saying it's so easy.
Why didn't you do that?
I blame you.
You know,
kind of thing.
It's not easy.
Probably there's so many different dynamics to every kid's experience.
So you know how,
and this is how the conversation kind of,
if I remember correctly,
kind of started when you were like,
Hey,
I have,
you know,
four kids or whatever,
and they're just different.
They are all,
and then I said,
this is before I had kids,
by the way.
So you weren't really feeling what else?
Yeah.
You,
you didn't,
you don't really care about that.
Well,
not to say you didn't get it anyway.
I said,
um,
okay.
It's kind of complicated.
So,
oh,
the kids are different.
Yeah.
But they're not just different,
like that's not it.
That's not,
yes,
yes.
Fully.
So consider every kid starting point is different.
So you can't expect to everyone,
every kids ending point to be the same.
Even though they go through the same experience,
just being the second born,
you're starting out as a completely different human being,
just being two years,
one year,
five years younger than your older brother.
That's what those minor variables end up creating some major,
major differences.
Yes,
of course.
At the,
at certain points in development,
they're going to have kind of the same needs but in a different environment.
So the way that you fulfilled those same needs with the first kid are going to
look different as far as them being translated with the second kid and the third
kid and the fourth,
however many kids you have.
So you just going to make slight adaptations to what you did to the second kid
than the first.
And to keep a handle of all those dynamics is it's hard.
So that's why it's like,
well,
not only that,
it's not an exact science.
Yeah.
And in the way kids react or way people,
it's not just,
we're not just talking about kids here,
we're talking about people you know,
because you get different people that you hire at different times or different
people that joined platoons at different times and they have a different
attitude.
So yeah,
you got to adjust.
But the bottom line is,
the thing that remains constant through all this is that if you're trying to
impart knowledge on people,
you need to take responsibility,
not just for showing them the knowledge,
but to making sure that they absorb the knowledge.
And the primary methodology of doing that is by explaining to people why they're
doing what they're doing and why you're telling them this and why this occurs.
So if,
like you said,
you tell your kid don't have a temper tantrum and then you never explained to
them,
here's why you don't want to have a temper tantrum.
But when you're doing this,
you could hurt yourself.
You could hurt other people.
You're going to do things that regret.
You can invite,
break something in the house.
I can't control you.
I can't bring you anywhere.
If you're going to act like this,
that means we can't go out and have fun.
So you've got to explain why.
And once you explain why,
then people have a better chance of absorbing the information.
But yes,
you as a trainer,
parent leader,
teacher,
has the responsibility,
not just to impart knowledge,
but to ensure that the knowledge is absorbed.
Yeah.
Rant.
Complete.
But,
uh,
and of course,
like I said,
it's for parenting.
It's not like just that easy.
No parenting is very difficult.
Leadership situations.
That's really a lot like Plinko consider it,
you know what I mean?
He started a different point and very well,
but yeah.
There you go.